how to and again
all all of this is really a movement
exercise it's not going to teach you
fencing it's not going to condition you
to the degree that other things can but
what it does work on is the in aspect of
movement and the young aspect of
movement for the internal aspects of the
art okay so count to encounter one I did
Bushido 10.com encounter a UFC or a DP
Miasha I'm going to move forward
the ski beyond aspect ski and the in
aspect the tight end is in the end of
every single count
so you can almost forget now okay so you
mean I have to shift into the Yong
position so need a toast then the foot
can press press and the time followed by
the ski
bring her on in and then the cutting now
you can either
but here if you want or another sukiyaki
come in and do they cut that parts are
relevant to me one two three then repeat
on the other side
okay all right let's try you're going to
test again they give me Ashley okay so
if by line of gravity is between my
bases support aspects between my feet
and I try to move my line of gravity
forward I cannot move oh I'm gonna lose
my balance I'm gonna push me back onto
that foot I have to change the ground
vector from the back foot to the front
foot and now that foot can drive and I
understand so he's pushing his
questioning he's pushing
we started should be able to intuit what
I'm doing again that that's what he's
trying to do so I Drive in creep the
ground vector on the front foot and then
I can move boom boom I'll do it again
boom pop so needs to chose now this
point is active and you can't project
you just like in yesterday's drill so
boom then ground boom and then boom and
ground again so we're doing two yards in
a road that's cow to Yong Yong Yong is
gonna be our drill Yong Yong Yong
eventually you can just walk that's the
skill we want but in the form
everything's exaggerated 1 rounding
driving on it grounding driving on it if
you can do that then I just want you to
walk that is changing the ground vector
on each foot dynamically so first row
shift dry shift dry if you can do that
time
I just want to see you all okay let's go
so posture is a bad word we say here
organization organize your body for the
internal aspect so why is posture bad
work because everyone's been told have a
good posture and this is not a martial
geometry my weights on my heels if you
pay attention I don't do any weight
shifting look what's happening you see
I'm not I'm about it's just I am
constantly dynamically kind of I go
adjusting my lower legs to keep me here
okay so if I keep good posture I can't
ever get my line and gravity to the
front foot which means I can't ever make
the front foot the ground vector you see
even if I shift my weight it's it's
still not here it's still not on the mid
foot of the front foot it's back here on
that heel and a lot on this leg I can't
do it okay so you not gonna have boom a
fight you can just like you're trying to
protect your chin top to have a fighting
camp or you have your leaning into the
recoil I have a fighting can but that's
not it either
okay same thing I can't get that foot
off the ground my mind widen gravity is
not on the mid-foot it's behind the heel
so when I go to
- okay what why it looks to be working
on you is that you push that guy with a
bracing angle and then you fill that gap
that he let happen from being pushed
back so your bouquet can be the one to
control you so lead into me like and
you're gonna move me move me first by
thing you see and then he goes forward
so what I'm going to do is he's going to
lean into me and then you're going if
you can't take that you can't take that
stuff you see so it's a mistake on who
gets on it again so try to have a
positive pressure ship in but I have a
can't to my body get out of the way I
move back you see there's I'm not up
here I'm here my pelvis is engaged won't
shift then this word can move but I'm
not moving like that okay let's try it
again
so with two young movements I should be
able out to cook you projections man you
are sleep today
okay so on the first one pull pull first
one move and push and you don't come
back in for the second one
so you mean full push back into the
second scheme the UV boom boom boom same
projection then I'll bring my hands
again so your movie
moving up move to your hands
oh okay let's go if you watch you don't
lift the sword here you going to shift
still not lifting boom save me on the
ski steep sword comes to me boom so
the same thing on the farm you just be a
body okay but be operate so don't step
in and expose yourself little threatened
with the ski threatened threatened booth
at the very last second this sword goes
up and down move out of the way hold
then move to the store and see so I'll
show the difference this is the rock
version Rock of version a one version
being right threaten Oh cut boom do it
wrong person mid-foot
I'm sorry midstance I'm double pivoting
it doesn't work go on like this
threatened threatened in to your eyes
hold it right there now threatened
threatened who cuts who to your hands
who oh you're right person pay attention
to the yard on the need one movie to
movie
[Music]
okay so we're now I'm doing a form
don't try to weigh the form Olympics
treat it more as a series of micro
drills okay don't move any faster than
you are consciously working on the
skillsets okay
so I'm moving toward a giraffe then
repeat take a pause everyone it doesn't
matter
[Applause]
choo-choo-choo Oh rotate okay let's go
and again because it's more important
this stuff then its ability to move my
body in this way I don't need the book
in okay I do the same form with my hand
so again
second point will do the cone here son
they cut the rotation so two into the on
position and that way I establish a
single pivot point not leave my line in
gravity too many feet do it double to
the point single pivot point rotate my
hips this foot moves with that hip just
like I was going to do a snap kick it
doesn't stay where it was so I'm all
twisted again this is not Marshall so
I'm here some of you are don't limiting
some of you are single pivoting but
disconnecting the foot from the hip so
you're not even pivoting all the way and
then you have this unmarshal stance so
you're gonna move my arms woo the foot
moves with your hip
steep shift rotate foot boost with the
hip cup
okay let's try when you do it without a
sword don't hold the sword if you're
going to put your hands there hold the
damn sword here like this same Center
home papi cut boom
here turn here to here then repeat
hey let's go